[Musique]
la première chose qui est absolument
importante c'est de garder tous ses
logiciels et ses systèmes d'opération à
jour derrière tous les logiciels qu'on
utilise
il ya dix équipes de programmes en prime
deux qui sont en charge de la sécurité
et puis quand ils vont trouver une
faille qui peut être exploitable et qui
vont qui vont la réparer et puis ben
c'est un peu cette réparation l'est qui
vont vous donner dans des dents des
mises à jour donc elle est con mais pose
ses navigateurs comme un peu ces
systèmes d'opération à jour ben c'est
comme si on avait si on continue à
habiter dans une maison qui avait des
fissures de plus en plus grande
[Musique]
à
l'époque du télétravail il ya un autre
conseil qui est clairement important
qu'on fait dans une navigation quand on
utilise un courriel c'est de se montrer
particulièrement critique avant de
cliquer sur trop mal n'importe quel lien
la majorité des virus se transmette à
travers des liens des pièces jointes
malveillantes
donc vraiment utiliser tout son sens
critique garder en tête que souvent les
attaques d'hameçonnage qui passe à
travers ces vecteurs d'attaqué que ce
soit des liens des fichiers ou peu
importe elles vont utiliser un certain
sentiment d'urgence pour créer un
contexte qui va nous pousser à cliquer
ou à télécharger sur un lien
[Musique]
il ya des coups qu'il était moins de
navigation et qui sont plus à des fins
commerciales donc qui sont là et qui
peuvent provenir soit des gogos a dit
mais aussi de plusieurs plusieurs autres
compagnies
dont facebook donc tous les géants du
web puis d'un enfant qu'est ce que vont
faire ces pistes et où ce qu'on se
promène pour essayer de construire un
profil de consommation et puis celles
souvent que on se rend compte des fois
qu'on commence à voir des publicités qui
sont un peu trop préciser tout ce qu'on
dit à comment ça c'est que facebook
tictacs et je savais que je consulte ce
type de matériel donc ça peut être un
peu invasif un outil je pense que j'aime
beaucoup pour justement et lucky tout
seul outil l'extension près de ciba dieu
c'est une extension qu'on installe sur
notre navigateur qui est compatible avec
la majorité des navigateurs et puis dans
le fond qui veut analyser les différents
témoins de navigation qui
qui sont présents et puis bah quand ils
vont voir qu'il ya un témoin navigation
qui nous suit un peu trop qui nous piste
de sites web un site web dès lors ils
vont commencer à les bloquer que près de
six dates jeu encore une fois joue un
bon rôle là dedans pour bloquer des
potentiels cookies qui pourrait être
monsieur donc encore une fois c'est une
solution que une fois qu'elle est
déployée on n'a pas besoin d'y retourner
d'être constamment et petit bouc et c6
relativement et hull
[Musique]
souvent qu'est ce que je dis c'est comme
faire un ménage du printemps moi
j'essaie de le faire à tous les mois
mais sinon à toutes les quelques mois
c'est une bonne en faire part à peu près
personne qui sont au courant de quelle
application récolte qu'elle donnait
quand la réalité c'est que la majorité
des applications récolte des données
même qu'on les utilise pas même quand on
les a on les actifs pauvres
intentionnellement donc juste le fait
des fois qu'ils soient présentes
certaines applications peu tout mais bon
quand même récolté des données parce que
c'est écrit en leurs conditions
d'utilisation c'est une bonne pratique
de dire si j'ai pas utiliser cette
application lieu depuis deux mois où
depuis un mois je reste pas en avoir
besoin c'est une excellente idée de
juste la dignité comme ça on sait que ça
n'en collecterons et au pire on l'a
retiré charge quand on en a besoin
nouveau
[Musique]
la première étape
cdc d'aller regarder dans les paramètres
du téléphone
c'est quoi les autorisations qu'on donne
à l'application avec une simple
modification de paramètres c'est
possible de bleu qui se donc encore une
fois les voir ces paramètres et puis ben
justement être visitée surtout pour les
applications qu'on ne risque pas de
supprimer et qu'on utilise assez
fréquemment de ça peut être une bonne
idée vraiment d'aller ouvrir le e de
pied de regarder c'est quoi les
paramètres c'est quoi les autorisations
qu'on donne à l'application sur notre
appareil donc allez voir est ce qui est
en ce moment tous mes pauses sont son
public est-ce qu'ils sont privés donc
allez allez vérifier et puis c'est pas
temporel à collecter des données mais
aussi pour de la surveillance
interpersonnelles des fois c'est
extrêmement facile d'en apprendre
beaucoup sur des individus juste en
vérifiant qu'est ce qu'ils publient de
manière publique est très conscient de
ce qu'on met dans l'espace public versus
qui se sont même dans l'espace privé
[Musique]